[Music]
tv legend tony dow has died e.t can't
confirm the sad news after his death was
prematurely announced on tuesday he was
77 years old tony starred in one of the
most iconic sitcoms of all time leave it
to beaver now look beef whatever you did
don't drag me into it
i think that it was the type of show
that the whole family can sit down
and really have a good time watching i
think it just made them feel real good
et's learned tony died wednesday morning
surrounded by family following a battle
with cancer he survived by his wife
lauren a grandchild and his adult son
christopher who mourned his father on
facebook writing although this is a very
sad day i have comfort and peace knowing
that he is in a better place he was the
best dad anyone could ask for
tony's part of television history leave
it to beaver he played the beaves older
brother wally across the show's six
seasons i'm only helping you because if
dad gets mad at you he always winds up
getting mad at me
tony continued popping up on tv over the
years when he wasn't acting tony worked
with his hands what happens as an actor
a lot of times there's some free time
yeah i like to do stuff et spent time at
home with tony and lauren the two were
married for over 40 years as he told us
tony was honored to be part of a
television legacy it was fun i mean it
was like growing up in disneyland it's
like a dream oh i think it's one of the
great television shows ever
[Music]
you